President Trump took to the Rose Garden
today and what did he do he announced
his new vaccine task force he set the
bar high with an aggressive timeline but
he gave America at the same time just
what she needed optimism for opening we
have the best and most devoted workers
ever to walk the face of the earth and
now we're combining all of these amazing
strengths for the most aggressive
vaccine project in history and I just
want to make something clear it's very
important vaccine or no vaccine we're
back and we're starting the process I
was doing the fist pump right there yes
well Democrats down on the other hand
they just prefer us to cower and crouch
in our houses they are pushing a friend
of mine called today panic porn they say
we need multiple vaccines not just one
but multiple they say the vaccines even
if we have them we don't know how
effective they'll be they see we need as
many as 300,000 government-paid tracers
and trackers hundreds of millions of
tests all of that before we can open
again and a purple unicorn on every
street corner the basic point here is
Democrats just don't trust you
and frankly they don't even like you so
of course they want you to stay indoors
off the streets and even out of your
churches with only a few exceptions blue
state governors all favor lockdowns
over Liberty one of the absolute worst
is Michigan's Gretchen Whitmer certainly
not an exercise of democratic principles
where we have free speech this is calls
to violence this is racist and
misogynistic these protests you know in
a in a perverse way make it like clear
that we're gonna have to stay in a
stay-home posture not behaving
Washington states jay Inslee is
punishing people with another extension
of his stay-at-home order
to the end of May now even though they
flatten the curve back in April in
Washington State this is insane
so when will he give up his vice grip on
power it's just a long ways away from
that because we know that the numbers
are still so high in our virus that it
just can't justify opening up all these
business right now it's not infections J
it's hospitalizations and deaths that's
what is the key here Illinois Governor
JB Pritzker's escalating his threats
against the disobedient businesses and
individual professionals that are
licensed by state agencies will be held
accountable for breaching Public Health
orders local law enforcement and the
Illinois State Police can and will take
action Oh big threat for a big man all
right well in gavin newsom California
local officials are slapping already
suffering businesses with
thousand-dollar citations and threats
for jail time for not complying with
everything from mask-wearing the social
distancing the way they're handling
their business is whether the stickers
are on the ground
LA County the most populous in the state
is extending its lock down at least
another three months I thought there was
a joke when I first heard it meanwhile
the mayor of LA
he's power tripping for still getting
reports each day of non-essential
businesses that continue to operate as
normal
this behavior is irresponsible and
selfish if we see continued
non-compliance they'll wind up facing
misdemeanor charge and DWP will step in
and shut off their water and power and
by the way these prohibitions and I love
that shutting off your water and your
the prohibitions they aren't written in
law they're done through gubernatorial
edict so as long as it's called an
emergency these governor's think that
they can trample on your rights with
impunity and they're doing that but
lawsuits are being filed that was good
news this week people who've never
protested before in their lives are
picking up placards and
protesting even when their livelihoods
are threatened if they still have jobs
or they're even being threatened with
jail time and you just get the sense
being being out there that Americans are
just fed up we have a daycare center in
Franklin County it's not open the whole
way so it's barely open enough to keep
us these things are typically a choice
there's a measles outbreak and all the
people were sick stay home
this is totally clipped they're making
the well stay home and that makes no
sense to me it'll make us that's
unlawful I think Americans need to
realize their freedoms are being taken
away and if they don't stand up for them
right now
there won't be any freedom to stand up
for but do any of you watching tonight
think that Pelosi and Schumer care about
those people of course they don't if
you've lost your job if your child is
struggling with distance learning don't
you love that phrase if you're
struggling with loneliness or addiction
or depression you're just collateral
damage on the way to the new normal all
of us are going to be living in a new
normal
whether that means wearing a mask
working in shifts
returning to our new normal with all of
the what we talked about through all
phases what we have to do is to design a
new normal a way of life to carry us to
the other side their idea of a new
normal not so much dr. Burks by the way
I'm talking about the politicians if
she's just caught got caught up in the
lingo it goes far beyond finding a
vaccine or hand-washing or covering your
sneezes that's all fine that's just
common sense the new normal for them is
basically everything that Hillary ran on
and loss plus some new radical ideas
from climate change to mass amnesty to
guaranteed income and to a massive
wealth tax if the pandemic ends
Democrats lose their leverage and they
know it that's why every chance they get
their media allies stoke the fears of a
weary and worried nation they want you
to be afraid very afraid because when
you're afraid they have more power and
they have more
authority to tell you how to live your
life and make no mistake they want this
to continue indefinitely they're playing
the only card they have the fear card
but there are increasing signs and these
poles and on the streets that it isn't
working there's traffic again around DC
Maryland and Virginia
I noticed it today and in the always
lively New Orleans we're gonna hear from
Raymond in a moment restaurants are
still shut down but folks are out and
about again many he told me are just
ignoring the masks shamers outside
coffee shops freedom brigades of
ordinary citizens are now activated
enterprising Americans are making
adjustments in innovating smartly
naturally NASCAR will be the first
national sport to reopen albeit without
fans West Virginia University's football
coach he announced the fall season is on
the SEC better follow talking to you
Alabama my friends at Cambria in
Minnesota put out a video of an old Paul
Harvey broadcast today that really
seemed apt for history I studied hours
and others the more certain I am that
there is one fertilizer essential to the
survival of civilization and that
fertilizer is sweat I mean the kind of
steamy stream a salty sweat that's wrung
from a man by hard physical work somehow
the threat gets into the soil of a farm
or a factory or a city or a state or a
nation and everything there abouts grows
tall and strong and tough enough to
stand yes tens
to stand against any storm the work
ethic of Americans the need to work and
work hard
of course he nailed it Paul Harvey
always did Americans have thrived on the
idea that although life is often hard
and challenging you and your family have
the freedom to decide how you want to
live it Democrats may live and shutdown
Nirvana but the emerging consensus is
this if you want to stay at home you can
stay at home but for the rest of us
we'll make our own decisions thank you
now we know more about this virus
extremely low lethality or otherwise
healthy younger Americans they do pretty
well seniors they need special care and
since the so-called experts say it will
be around forever it's time to move on
with our lives
the testing issue is just another
Democrat red herring more impossible
hoops to jump through testing and
tracking for the rest of your life since
the virus will be with us forever just
like the flu they say the virus has
taken many lives and it's awful it's a
tragedy it's wrecked a once great
economy but it is also shown for all the
world to see who these new radical
Democrats really are and what they want
their petty dictators who want to
fundamentally change the America we love
you know the old normal the masks are
off and that's the angle